Raphaël Jacob bonsoir
bon là un autre ballon abattu pour
s'empresse le dire parce qu'il y a pas
d'image là en passant que vous allez
voir mesdames et messieurs c'est l'autre
ballon ça c'est celui dont je vous
parlais c'est l'autre ballon de la
semaine dernière là on s'emprise le dire
comment on comprend ça c'est le mystère
total aujourd'hui c'est le ministère
totale de 1 parce que un petit peu comme
le Pentagone et le département d'État
l'ont dit très clairement dans les
dernières heures on a aucune espèce
d'idée à quelle entité c'est relié non
partent pas simplement nécessairement
d'un gouvernement ça peut être même
identité entièrement privée donc selon
la version officielle des autochtens
Américaines présentement on est
essentiellement dans le noir en même
temps je pense qu'il faut réaliser que
lorsque vous parlez de parcours du
premier ballon et maintenant de celui-ci
dans les deux cas ça a commencé au même
endroit c'est-à-dire en survenant
l'Alaska donc quand même ce point commun
là qui est quand même pas banal et je
m'attendais ceci c'est le premier ballon
le parcours qu'on a fait là
il est parti les Chinois l'ont reconnu
que c'était eux ils disaient que c'est
un ballon météorologique mais évidemment
non et enfin tout indique que non et là
il est passé par l'Alaska il est
descendu à quand le bébé britannique
puis a fait le tour il y a traversé les
Américains les États-Unis absolument et
ce deuxième objectif aujourd'hui ce
serait trouvé à peu près à la frontière
entre l'Alaska justement et le Canada
une fois que tout ça c'est dit je pense
que il y a un point fondamental qu'on a
toujours garder en tête lorsqu'ils du
premier ballon de ce deuxième objet là
il y a énormément de choses qu'on a
c'est pas et gardez toujours en tête ce
cybatrice il y a ce que les autorités
américaines elles-mêmes ne savent pas et
il y a ce qu'elles savent et qu'elles ne
nous disent pas donc comme membres du
grand public est quand même analyste qui
façonne dans la vie là il faut quand
même avoir je crois une dose de modestie
de prudence donc gardons-nous tout au
moins pour ma part de plus en plus de
détails tant qu'on ne sera pas davantage
renseigne et la semaine dernière
beaucoup d'analyses il y en a eu plein
c'est que là on l'a vu il y a eu des
images là ça c'est des images de la
destruction samedi mais s'il y avait pas
eu d'image peut-être une zone n'aurait
pas parlé non plus
parce qu'il faut quand même dire en
conclusion que le secrétaire d'État a
annulé une visite à Pékin à cause du
ballon chinois là c'est pas rien non
seulement c'est pas rien mais il faut
réaliser la réponse à ça de la part du
gouvernement chinois et la
contre-réponse gouvernement américain
c'est-à-dire que du côté chinois après
qu'on est abattu le ballon venant de
chaîne ce que le gouvernement de
Monsieur schi est allait dire c'est que
non seulement c'est une surréaction de
la part des États-Unis mais que c'était
carrément une un viol du droit
international selon les Chinois encore
une fois est-ce que les Américains sont
en train de faire comme les postes en
fait c'est carrément de préparer de
nouvelles sanctions contre le
gouvernement chinois a donc ce qui a
commencé comme pour certains un espèce
de faits divers dans dans le ciel mais
c'est en train de devenir vraiment une
nouvelle dispute géopolitique entre les
deux plus grandes puissances de la
planète et Joe Biden qui ne veut pas
avoir l'air faible qui donc parce que
déjà on dit pourquoi il a attendu autant
de jours pour la batte etc le premier ok
petit extrait sonore très court de mardi
discours sur l'état de l'Union on écoute
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai eu un peu de grabuge nous on
est habitué là il y en a qui s'énervent
avec ça mais dans les périodes de
questions c'est rien ça s'arrêtait même
une période de questions calme Raphaël
son comparaissait avec ce qui se passe
dans notre Parlement ou même en
Grande-Bretagne mais dans les discours
sur l'état de l'Union c'est plus
inhabituel comment vous avez perçu ce
qui est arrivé puis l'impact de ce
discours d'un point de vue stratégique
avant même de se parler de l'aspect
décorum d'un point de vue purement
stratégique à la fois sur le fond et sur
la forme monsieur Biden en sa grand
gagnant sur le fond d'abord avant tout
parce que de quoi ce qui était question
spécifiquement lorsqu'on a vu les
républicains comme Madame green réagir
de la sorte de la protection de
programme chérie par la grande majorité
des Américains depuis maintenant des
générations comme madeker donc le
programme d'assurance maladie pour les
personnes plus âgées aux États-Unis
assurance publique fédérale et le fameux
programme sociaux sécurité qui lui
remonte à l'air de Frankland derrière
là aussi au niveau fédéral un certain
système public de pension de vieillesse
dans les deux cas ce sont des terrains
croyez-moi sur lesquels monsieur Biden
présumait c'est une présomption
présentement qu'il se représente en 2024
va vouloir mener c'est ma prochaine
question mais ok ça a été un bon
discours pour lui là oui donc sur le
fond pour ça et sur la forme le simple
contraste parce que vous savez pour le
président des États-Unis c'est vrai pour
Monsieur Biden comme c'est vrai c'était
vrai pour tous ces prédécesseurs il y a
un aspect très théâtral très performatif
au discours sur l'état de l'Union mais
il faut indiquer les caméras ne sont pas
seulement braquées sur la président
elles sont aussi braquées tout au long
de la soirée sur les membres élus du
parti adverse qui sont eux aussi présent
et de voir des gens comme Madame green
ce n'était pas la seule agir de façon
aussi déjantée et aussi irrespectueuse
parce que vous avez raison de mentionner
si on compare au système canadien ou
encore plus au système britannique c'est
vrai que ça peut avoir l'air
pardonne-moi l'expression mais de la
petite bière or dans le système
américain où on n'a pas de de
performance de la sorte d'habitude
plutôt de contre-performance
ça a vraiment des données et c'est
surtout bien c'est venu bien faire
apparaître le président alors prochaine
question il y en a deux une est-ce que
Joe Biden se représente et l'autre
question ça va être qu'est-ce que ça
nous dit sur les républicains tout ce
qu'on a vu mardi on va commencer avec la
question la plus difficile parce
qu'évidemment ce n'est pas de mon
ressort plus que c'est du vote Patrice
ça va être la décision ultimement d'un
homme et de ce qu'on a comprend
largement également de son épouse son
épouse être entièrement d'accord avec
une prochaine campagne et Monsieur byden
je vais simplement me contenter
prudemment de répondre ce cicatrice en
le voyant agir ne serait-ce que mardi
dernier il n'agissait pas il ne parlait
pas il ne se comportait pas comme un
homme qui était sur le point de passer
le flambeau à quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est
la première chose à ce statut tout est
possible encore une fois la décision va
lui revenir mais je serais
personnellement surpris je leur ai été
avant mardi je le serai encore plus
depuis mardi si il ne se représente pas
mais encore une fois il aurait quel âge
en 2024 donc il aura il aurait oui juste
avant protection il aurait 80 un 82 ans
81 ans ce qui est clair c'est qu'à la
fin de son mandat il dépasserait les 85
ans servir un deuxième mandat entier il
aurait si finalement est bonne 86 ans
donc ça va être un facteur à me garder
en tête que de l'autre côté c'est parti
choisir à nouveau dans notre chambre ce
qui est vraiment pas qui non plus on a
également un autre octogénaire donc ça
dépend aussi cette joute politique là de
qui les républicains vont choisir de
leur côté si Monsieur Biden revient du
côté démocrate donc est-ce que quelqu'un
lui souffle dans le cou à Monsieur Biden
du côté démocrate la réponse honnête
c'est non présentement et il faut rester
très rapidement je vais prendre 10
secondes pour ça parce que je pense que
c'est trop peu expliqué trop peu compris
ce qui l'aide contre intuitivement et de
façon un petit peu malsaine c'est en
fait la personne qui est son numéro 2
le simple fait Patrice c'est que quand
de tels problèmes depuis les débuts de
son mandat comme vice-présidente et
qu'il y a de tels dotes au sein du parti
démocrate oublié le côté républicain au
sein du parti démocrate de la voir comme
porte-étendard présidentiel du parti en
2024 qu'on ne pose pas monsieur Biden
présentement vers la porte parce qu'on
se dit si c'est elle qui est l'héritage
héritière naturelle ça vient avec des
problèmes pour la partie il reste une
minute et les républicains eux qu'est-ce
que ça nous disait cette soirée-là sur
l'avenir Trump parce que il y a encore
des gens qu'est-ce que ça nous dit à la
porte-parole que 40 ans qu'est-ce que ça
nous disait sur l'avenir des
républicains en moins d'une minute on va
faire un bel exercice pour dans le choix
rapidement en fait votre question est
assez simple parce qu'il a encore des
chances absolument qu'il a des chances
le dernier sondage national auprès des
électeurs républicains qui étaient
publiés 7 semaines tout de suite après
le discours sur l'état de l'Union
montrant en fait que devant un ensemble
d'autres adversaires républicains Donald
Trump était 10 points à l'avance par
rapport à son
éventuelle possible concurrent c'est à
dire monsieur de synthèse la fleur donc
tout est possible pour ce qui est de
Monsieur Trump maintenant pour ce qui
est de l'avenir du passé républicain de
façon plus large ça sera sur ceci
ça va se jouer dans les à peu près 12
prochains mois c'est très très incertain
parce que contrairement à 2020 oui
Donald Trump pourrait encore être le
candidat du parti mais ce n'est vraiment
vraiment pas acquis de la compétition et
non seulement il voyait en avoir mais il
risque dès la semaine prochaine dès
mercredi d'avoir une au moins une
première adversaire officiellement dans
la course contre lui et ce n'est pas
n'importe laquelle ni qui est Élie qui
est l'ex ambassadrice à l'ONU qu'il
avait lui-même nommé donc une première
marque de son cabinet absolument ça va
être intéressant Raphaël vraiment c'est
bien bravo vous avez relevé le défi
merci beaucoup à vendredi prochain si
tout va bien et bon super bon goût
salut